[Applaus]
[Musik]
in weniger als zehn tagen brachte die
republik afghanistan zusammen und die
taliban griffen die macht wir sprechen
hier über eine truppe mittelalterlichen
gotteskrieger welche durch die usa und
ihre verbündeten in zwei jahrzehnten nie
gänzlich besiegt werden konnte und
welche nun in der lage war das ganze
land in die weniger als nur zwei wochen
einzunehmen nur eine einzige kleine
provinz namens punch ihr das
sprichwörtliche gallische dorf in
afghanistans schaffte es der
radikalislamischen lawine zu trotzen sie
ist nun mittelpunkt des aufkeimenden
widerstands
der vormarsch der taliban vollzog sich
einer derart atemberaubenden
geschwindigkeit dass wir alle leicht mit
ansehen konnten wie sie die reste
amerikanischen truppen an die wand
drücken diese hatten eigentlich den
auftrag eine geregelte evakuierung zu
ermöglichen diese mündete jedoch
zeitweise im totalen chaos nach 20
jahren abertausenden verlorenen
menschenleben und kosten von über 2,2
billionen dollar wiederholten sich die
dramatischen bilder des us rückzugs aus
saigon diesmal allerdings in einem viel
größeren um schlimmeren ausmaß wie
konnte es nur so weit kommen wie konnte
das alles passieren und wie gelang es
den taliban so schnell die macht zu
ergreifen
amerikanische truppen können und sollten
nicht in einem krieg kämpfen und einem
krieg sterben in die afghanischen kräfte
nicht bereit sind für sich selbst zu
kämpfen joe biden präsident der
vereinigten staaten
das sind beiden hat gelogen und muss
sich schämen wir haben 70.000 männer im
krieg verloren wir haben 95 prozent
aller operationen 2014 durchgeführt
gerade als wir fahrer konnten wurden die
luftunterstützung die versorgungskette
und unsere kommunikation eingestellt
sagt karas afghanisches kommando
sie haben uns die hände auf den rücken
gebunden und die heimat verkauft
verdammt sei der reiche mann und seine
bande wir werden afghanistan von diesen
terroristen befreien die geschichte wird
über garni den liebhaber ihrer bande
urteilen general bis mahler mohammadi
verteidigungsminister der islamischen
republik afghanistan
wohlgemerkt bei der islamischen republik
afghanistan handelt es sich nicht um den
neuen taliban start sondern um die such
eben gestürzte demokratische republik
die annahme war wohl der streitkräfte
werden nach 20 jahren der kostspieligen
ausbildung und ausrüstung durch
internationale truppen irgendwie
abwehrbereit mit hilfe der mehr als 80
milliarden dollar teuren ausrüstung und
350.000 man in der armee und polizei
hätte die republik afghanistan den
taliban angeblich widerstand leisten
soll zumindest ist das die geschichte
die uns verkauft wurde
dreiundzwanzigster juli 2018 wir sind
auf dem richtigen weg das afghanische
militär um die polizei demonstrieren
ihren willen zum erfolg johnny leoni
christen junia vier sterne general und
oberbefehlshaber der us-truppen in
afghanistan von 2016 bis 2018
[Musik]
wir versorgen unsere afghanischen
partner mit allen mitteln ich betone
allen mitteln training und ausrüstung
eines modernen militärs bestellten
fortschrittliche waffen zur verfügung
was müsste geschehen damit sich eine
armee dieser 2014 für mehr als 95
prozent der militäroperationen im land
verantwortlich war plötzlich auflöst wie
ein zuckerwürfel in der badewanne was
spielte sich jedoch gar nichts dann ab
damit die taliban gegen so wenig
widerstand wieder an die macht kommen
konnte der fall afghanistans und die
jüngste demütigende niederlage der
amerikanischen großmacht könnte eine
zeitenwende darstellen deswegen haben
wir hier bei visual politik eine ganze
video technologie vorbereitet damit ihr
die ganze geschichte ihre hintergründe
und alle wichtigen zusammenhänge
erfahren die vergangenheit die gegenwart
und die zukunft des längsten krieges der
usa einen krieg zu verlieren ist nie
besonders angenehm aber kaum jemand
konnte sich jene bilder der niederlage
flucht verzweiflung und des chaos
vorstellen erzeugen wir alle geworden
sind extrem hässliche bilder die für
immer eine schwere belastung der
regierung beiden darstellen werden ein
schandmal der fahrlässigkeit
verantwortungslosigkeit und des
missmanagements das ausmaß an
gleichgültigkeit inkompetenz der
regierung von joe biden und kamera
harris gegenüber afghanistan übersteigt
die grenzen menschlicher
vorstellungskraft und selbst der abzug
der sowjets nach deren verlorenen
afghanistan feldzug erscheint einem im
nachhinein als geordnet es gab nichts
was ich oder irgendjemand anders gesehen
hat was auf dem zusammenbruch dieser
regierungen elf tagen hindeutete general
mark milli vorsitzenden des generalstabs
der vereinigten staaten in diesem ersten
video unserer afghanistan reihe werden
wir uns auf die vier schlüsselfaktoren
konzentrieren welche die taliban ihren
überwältigenden erfolg zu verdanken
haben wir sprechen hier über vier
szenarien die eingetreten sind und die
sich gegenseitig ergänzen
bisher ist zwar schwer abzuschätzen
welches gewicht genau jedes von ihnen
hatte aber wir wissen dass sie alle
entscheidend zum historischen debakel in
afghanistan beigetragen haben
wir wurden betrogen uns wurde gesagt
hast ein friedensabkommen erreicht ist
eine übergangsregierung wird gebildet
hört auf zu kämpfen zieht euch in eure
basel zurück dann wurde uns befohlen
alles an die taliban so übergeben ich
werde mehr schreiben wenn ich dazu in
der lage bin merkt euch ein weiteres
nine eleven wird kommen bin am boden
zerstört sein fasst afghanischer
kommandos salat
also wollte erfahren wie genau
afghanistan gefallen ist dann hört jetzt
gut zu
der verrat von doha
stell dir vor du bist der präsident der
vereinigten staaten und 20 jahren kamen
tausende von opfern und einer hand
kosten steckst du in einem krieg fest
von denen du weißt dass du ihn niemals
gewinnen kannst oder besser gesagt dass
der preis die kosten die opfer um ihn zu
gewinnen nicht zu rechtfertigen sind ich
erinnere mich an afghanistan als an
einen staubigen besen albtraum eines
ortes voller stolzer mutiger menschen
die uns dort nicht haben wollten die usa
stell dir vor dass du genau in diesem
moment einen plan präsentiert bekommst
herr präsident wir haben die
zauberformel gefunden um aus diesen
hexenkessel zu entkommen wir verfügen
über einen plan um weitere opfer zu
vermeiden
den wirtschaftlichen verfall in der
krieg mit sich bringt zu stoppen die
entstehung neuer terror gruppen zu
verhindern und gleichzeitig
möglicherweise einige geo ökonomische
gewinne zu erzielen wäre gut nicht wahr
[Musik]
nun stell dir vor dass dieser plan
speziell darin besteht entpackt mit den
taliban zu schließen und ihnen sogar den
zugang zur macht zu erleichtern ja du
hast richtig gehört genauso lieb ist in
der praxis ab
dem jahr 2018 forderte die regierung
trump pakistan auf mullah abdul ghani
baradar freizulassen und
us-außenminister mike kompon traf sich
mit ihm um zu verhandeln baradar ist
kein geringerer als der aktuelle
politische führer der taliban
das ergebnis war dass im februar 2020
das duo abkommen unterzeichnet wurde ein
abkommen gegen das sich die afghanische
regierung von garnier vehement wehrte
wenn auch letztlich vergeblich das
abkommen legt einen zeitplan für den
abzug der internationalen truppen die
freilassung von abertausenden
inhaftierten taliban sowie die
reduzierung der luftangriffe und auch
der us militär operation gegen taliban
fest und was versprachen dafür im
gegenzug die treiber nun dass sie keine
internationalen truppen angreifen keine
anderen terrorgruppen unterstützen bzw
beherbergen und mit der afghanischen
regierung über eine politische lösung
des konflikts verhandelt werden
zumindest denn die sehne details die als
licht gekommen sind denn ein großteil
der vereinbarung wird nach wie vor
geheim gehalten mit anderen worten die
amerikaner handelten den fahrplan für
die zukunft afghanistans nicht mit der
afghanischen regierung aus diese saß
noch nicht einmal am tisch sondern mit
den taliban
reykjavik
[Musik]
das durch abkommen verschaffte den
taliban eine einjährige gnadenfrist sie
konnten sich neu gruppieren planen ihre
nachschublinien stärken und sich frei
bewegen ohne angst vor us bombardements
henry watkins mitglieder des ios
institute of peace
aus einer gewissen perspektive macht das
durchaus sehen
denkt mal drüber nach wenn man mal das
moralische problem völlig ausblendet
welches ein pakt mit einer bundle
mittelalterlicher fanatiker wir den
taliban darstellt könnten die vorteile
eines solchen abkommens hat durchaus
verlockend klingen keine weiteren
eigenen verluste kein nährboden für
andere terrorgruppen du wirst das land
verlassen können ohne dass dort zum
beispiel sei eys oder al qaida wieder
erstarkt und du wirst in der lage sein
eine aufmerksamkeit und deine ressourcen
auf deine wahre priorität zu lenken den
pazifik und die eindämmung der
expansionsgelüste chinas und wenn die
taliban an der macht sind dann ja dann
könnte die neue stabilität im land sogar
ganz neue chancen eröffnen ihr habt euch
nicht verhört was mich das mal kurz
erklären afghanistan ist ein land das
erreicht man vielen rohstoffen die von
der technologie industrie heißt begehrt
kupfer lithium kobalt new york seltene
erden sowie gold und uran laut einem
bericht des pentagons den die new york
times im jahr 2010 zitierte hat
afghanistan sogar das potenzial dass
saudi arabien des lithiums zu werden
jedes metalls aus dem die ganzen kurs
der elektro fahrzeuge hergestellt werden
und nicht nur das es gibt auch projekte
wie die tapi gaspipeline ein 1800
kilometer lange pipeline projekt das
erdgas von turkmenistan nach pakistan
indien und china transportieren könnte
und sich ganz zufällig im besitz des ccn
west will konzernchef ron befindet
es würde chinas abhängigkeit von
russischem erdgas reduzieren und
gleichzeitig die strategische bedeutung
des irans verringern das alles sind geo
ökonomische und geopolitische interessen
der vereinigten staaten tja und jetzt
februar 2021 besuchten die taliban in
einem offenbar von den usa selbst
koordiniert und besucht minister und
versprachen dieses projekt unter ihren
eigenen schutz zu stellen denn der
verlauf der pipeline muss durch
afghanistan führen werden das bisherige
problem war halt dass man für die
ausbeutung von rohstoffen oder für den
aufbau von energie transport
infrastruktur wie pipelines politische
stabilität braucht
und so lange man mit den taliban auf
kriegsfuß steht ist diese eben nicht
besonders groß dass doha abkommen war
daher eine gelegenheit diese geo
ökonomischen probleme ein für allemal zu
lösen eine kooperation im stile der sc
ii und das erklärt warum die usa ihre
operationen gegen die taliban praktisch
eingestellt haben obwohl diese ihre
angriffe gegen armee und institutionen
des demokratischen afghanistans derart
intensiviert haben dass die ono 2020 als
das gewalttätigste jahr im land seit
beginn ihrer aufzeichnungen bezeichnete
sicher auf den ersten blick mögen die
duma vereinbarungen das gesamte szenario
erklären aber sie reichen nicht aus um
vollständig zu verstehen warum um alles
in der welt sich die afghanische armee
so schnell auflöste denn das war eine
entwicklung welche sogar die
us-regierung selbst völlig unvorbereitet
traf obwohl natürlich die wahrheit ist
dass die fast vollständige reduzierung
der luftangriffe der abzug der partner
der us luftwaffe und die daraus
resultierende demoralisierung der
truppen eine schlüsselrolle gespielt hat
also aufgebracht
linderung als norm
[Musik]
es ist nicht das erste mal das ist so
eine auflösung der durch die usa
ausgebildeten ausgerüsteten afghanischen
armee kam im herbst 2015 siegten rund
500 taliban bei der offensive in der
provinz kunduz 3000 afghanische soldaten
bzw polizisten und eroberten zum ersten
mal eine provinzhauptstadt anschließend
überrollten auch in der provinz helmand
etwa 1800 taliban fast 4500 afghanischen
soldaten und polizisten
wie flüchteten sie hatten alles was sie
brauchten truppen was munition und sie
gaben einfach auf wo man der der
afghanischen armee
[Musik]
eine wichtige anmerkung damit wir uns
nicht missverstehen
wir wollen damit nicht sagen dass sich
die afghanische armee im kampf gegen die
taliban nicht bemüht hat über all die
jahre mussten die afghanen die hauptlast
des konfliktes tragen allein armee und
polizei haben rund 70.000 tote zu
beklagen tatsache ist jedoch dass sowohl
die motivation als auch
materialknappheit an der tagesordnung
waren so war jetzt fragst du dich sicher
wie verdammt noch mal in einer armee in
die so viel geld gepumpt wurde mehr als
80 milliarden dollar so großer mangel
herrschen kann nun ein grund liegt im
durch die vereinigten staaten in
dortmund aufbau des militärs sie haben
die afghanische armee nach ihren eigenen
ebenbild zusammengestellt als über das
ganze land verteilt das netzwerk weit
voneinander im center außenposten und
basen ein netzwerk dessen
funktionsfähigkeit komplett abhängig ist
von einem komplexen logistik und
nachschuss system bestehend aus
flugverbindungen durch flugzeuge und
hubschrauber und die afghanen waren kurz
gesagt einfach nicht in der lage ein
solch komplexes nachschub netzwerk
nachhaltig zu managen als die provinz
kundus an die taliban viel wurden viele
soldaten getötet wir waren umzingelt es
gab keine luftunterstützung in den
letzten minuten sagte uns unser
kommandeur dass die nichts mehr für uns
tun können und dass es besser sei zu
fliehen sie haben alle den kampf
aufgegeben und sind geflohen ab 29
jähriger afghanischer soldat
wieso aber waren die afghanen eigentlich
nicht imstande einer militärorganisation
nach amerikanischem vorbild langfristig
funktionstüchtig zu halten nun sie
komplexe inkompetent zu erklären würde
zu kurz greifen der hauptgrund liegt
hier näher in ihrem vielleicht
auffälligsten charakteristikum der
letzten jahrzehnte der massiven
korruption denn trotz der enormen
geldsummen die von den amerikanern
ausgegeben wurden enthielten die
afghanischen soldaten nur ein lächerlich
kümmerlichen salt manchmal mussten sie
monatelang ohne bezahlung auskommen und
sogar munition war knapp und als die
taliban kam verfuhren sich ganz nach
pablo escobars devise platte blau silber
oder blei sie stellten ihre gegner vor
die wahl zu ihnen überlaufen und als
belohnung frische ausrüstung mehr geld
und man höre und staune gar frauen
bekommen und die attraktive sterben in
der tat muss man sich diesen handel
nicht auf individueller basis vorstellen
da wurden nicht einzelne soldaten
angesprochen und mit einem raise mädel
zur relation geködert nein bereits seit
vielen monaten beginnend mit dem tag der
vertrag schließung in doha wurden viele
dieser deals zwischen den taliban und
der afghanischen stammesführern und
militärkommandeure abgeschlossen welche
die ihnen unterstellten truppen
eingezogen
keine region ist durch kampf gefallen
sondern durch psychologische
kriegsführung aber das tarakuli
kommandeur des 217 afghanischen armee
kurs
jeder hat einfach seinen waffen
abgegeben und ist geflohen wir haben
keine hilfe von der zentralregierung
bekommen so dass der bezirk kampflos
gefallen ist dreimal ein 25 jähriger
afghanischer soldat
[Musik]
tatsächlich gegen den regierungstruppen
die vorräte aus und ein knurrender magen
schimpft halt nicht gerne aber moment
mal wenn es den afghanischen soldaten
hauptsächlich um essen und geld ging saß
da anders m nicht am längeren hebel wo
verdammt noch mal sind die 80 milliarden
dollar der us steuerzahler gelandet wie
sich nun zeigt versicherte ein guter
teil des geldes an orten wie dubai oder
katar zum beispiel wurde ahmed sia
massud ein ehemaliger vizepräsident
afghanischen regierung beschuldigt mehr
als 50 millionen dollar nach dubai
geschleust zu haben wobei er in einer
luxuriösen villa lebte und in rolls
royce herum vor und das ist kein
einzelfall
weil könnte unzählige dieser beispiele
aufhören top militärs und
regierungsbeamte logan ungeniert über
die zahl ihrer soldaten und steckten den
salt für diese phantoms soldaten einfach
in die eigene tasche den tausenden und
abertausenden von fällt als dieser
systematischen betrug eines tages
aufflog und den amerikanern klar wurde
dass sie den sold für über 300.000 man
die wirkliche zahl aber kaum mehr als
250.000 beträgt war es eigentlich schon
zu spät es hatte sich ein durch und
durch parasitäres netzwerk in der
gesamten militärorganisation etabliert
denn auch von legitimen soll zahlungen 2
viele hohe kommandeure meist einen guten
teil für sich ab was die soldaten noch
weiter demotivierte
die amis versuchten dem ausufernden geld
wurde mit hilfe eines elektronischen
zahlungssystem zu werben aber trotzdem
blieb ein großteil der probleme bestehen
die findigen kommandeure fanden immer
wieder schlupflöcher zur
selbstbereicherung aber es ging nicht
nur um die an der spitze ganz und gar
nicht wieder her so scheer korruption
war allgegenwärtig und eine ganz
logische folge des systems denn jede
afghanischer soldat war sich genau
darüber bewusst dass seine vorgesetzten
klauten wie die haben während er kommt
200 dollar salt im monat bekommen wenn
dieser denn überhaupt ausgezahlt wurde
und wenn man einem solchen soldaten den
ausrüstung im wert von tausenden von
dollar gibt greift dieser daneben zur
selbsthilfe und das ergebnis ist ein
blühender schwarzmarkt im wahrsten
wortsinn an sichtbarsten wurde diese
tatsache als das pentagon versucht hat
die afghanische armee mit
nachtsichtgeräten auszustatten egal wie
oft die geliefert wurden sie
verschwanden immer wieder genauso wie
fahrzeugteile waffen munition treibstoff
und viele andere dinge das prinzip war
immer das gleiche die amis zahlten die
rechnungen und konnten die verwendung
der mittel kaum kontrollieren der grund
die sich immer weiter verschärfenden
sicherheitslage im land
2016 konnten die us kontrolleure ohne
schwer gepanzerter konvois nicht einmal
mehr afghanische sicherheitskräfte im
eigenen kabuler büros treffen zuletzt
konnten sie nur noch der hubschrauber
reisen ein veritabler teufelskreis hinzu
kamen dass sich viele afghanische
soldaten und polizisten zur
alltäglichkeit wird mit dem eintreiben
von bestechungsgeldern an
kontrollpunkten dies würde dazu dass ein
großer teil der gesellschaft wenig
vertrauen in sie und null respekt vor
ihnen hatte die polizei wurde zur
meistgehassten institution im land und
die taliban nun die taten im grunde das
gleiche aber mit einem entscheidenden
unterschied sie organisieren die
korruption ganz offiziell das heißt man
muss bei ihnen nur einmal zahlen nicht
wie bei der polizei ständig
das prinzip der taliban ist wenn du
einmal die steuer also bestechungen
bezahlt hast geben sie dir eine quittung
die im ganzen land gilt und du wirst
nicht noch einmal aufgefordert die
steuer also bestechung zu bezahlen
polizisten hingegen stellen keine
quittungen die bestechungsgelder aus die
sie erpressen 18 jahren
stellvertretender leiter der
handelskammer in der provinz herat
wenn man also eine solche armee hat die
größtenteils schlecht ausgebildet
schlecht ausgerüstet und unmotiviert ist
ist das ergebnis genau das was wir
gesehen haben als die taliban kamen und
sie bedrohten führen viele truppen oder
wechselten die seiten übergaben ihre von
den usa gelieferte militärische
ausrüstung an die taliban ein phänomen
das nicht noch weiter steigerte als sie
sahen dass sie nicht mehr die
unterstützung der amerikaner hatten und
meine lieben zuschauer die anis legten
in den letzten tagen ihr dasein es
wirklich eine unvergleichliche
demonstration ihrer gleichgültigkeit und
respektlosigkeit an den tag so verließen
sie die riesige luftwaffenbasis in
wagram in der x 10.000 us soldaten
stationiert waren über nacht ohne ihren
afghanischen verbündeten auch nur kurz
bescheid zu geben die verdutzten
afghanen waren tausende zurückgelassene
fahrzeuge vor darunter hunderte von
panzerfahrzeugen daher stellt sich ganz
kleine frage warum sollten sie ihr leben
riskieren so eine sache von der selbst
die amerikaner nichts mehr hielten und
alles um sich herum sowieso völlig
korrupt war dieser psychologische faktor
definierte die afghanischen streitkräfte
auf ein niveau das eigentliche weit
unter den 167.000 mann lag über die die
armee offiziell verfügen sollte die
quellen legen nahe dass es in jedem
augenblick der wahrheit kommt 50.000
soldaten gab die bereit waren zu kämpfen
aber ohne jegliche strategie im land
verstreut waren darüber hinaus mit
extrem schlechter ausrüstung und ohne
versorgung und nachschub das ergebnis
kennen wir mittlerweile alle aber es
gibt noch zwei weitere faktoren die der
berücksichtigen müssen um das gesamtbild
und das gesamte ausmaß dieses fiaskos zu
verstehen auch gepasst
fatale fehler und pakistan
es ist klar dass die vereinigten staaten
in afghanistan viele fehler gemacht
haben der vielleicht bedeutendste von
allen weil ihr versagen eine armee und
sicherheitskräfte zu schaffen die
tatsächlich in der lage wären die
taliban zu besiegen und hierbei weisen
viele analysten auf ein ganz bestimmtes
problem hin die zeit die es brauchte um
eine afghanische armee zusammen zu
stellen denn eine armee und eine polizei
von grund auf neu aufzubauen ist gar
nicht so einfach und schon gar nicht in
afghanistan wo es aufgrund von
erlittenen verlusten eine riesige
personalfluktuation
wir müssen den amerikanischen soldaten
nicht beibringen das gesetz zu befolgen
keine bestechungsgelder anzunehmen und
die menschenrechte zu respektieren sie
kommen in unsere streitkräfte und haben
diese dinge bereits verinnerlicht wir
versuchen militärs nach unserem vorbild
zu schaffen und das ist oft nicht
deckungsgleich in den politischen und
sozialen umständen in denen diese
streitkräfte operieren michael in der
ehemalige kommandeur des us special
operations command center
[Musik]
tatsache ist dass nachdem die
vereinigten staaten unter präsident
george bush die afghanische büchse der
pandora öffneten und in das land ein
marschierten die taliban zunächst
besiegt wurden für einige jahre
herrschte eine gewisse ruhe aber
besessen vom irak der unvorstellbare
summen verschlang die dann an anderer
stelle fehlten begehen präsident bush
und sein verteidigungsminister donald
rumsfeld zwei verhängnisvolle fehler die
den grundstein für ein noch
verhängnisvoller sr belegten
erstens legten sie das angebot wieder
taliban-führer ab über eine politische
lösung zu verhandeln und zweitens
bestand sie darauf dass die afghanischen
streitkräfte auf eine lächerliche größe
beschränkt bleiben kaum 50.000 mann die
ein riesiges land kontrollieren sollten
das was doppelt so groß ist wie
deutschland und tausendfach so unwegsam
ein vielvölkerstaat bestehend aus 19
teilweise tief miteinander verfeindeten
ethnien in einem wort ein pulverfass aus
dieser wohl bekannten tatsachen und
bestanden bush und rumsfeld auf der
einen seite auf ihrer operation enduring
freedom zu deutsch operation andauernden
freiheit und auf der anderen seite
strichen sie die ausgaben dafür extrem
zusammen besoldung versorgung und
ausbildung der afghanischen truppen
wurden während ihrer amtszeit deswegen
auf einem absoluten minimum gehalten bis
rumsfeld 2006 abtrat und die taliban
ihre angriffe intensivierten waren
gerade einmal 26 tausend afghanische
soldaten ausgebildet und ausgerüstet
worden rumsfeld skies er richtig auf
lange sicht als sehr kostspielig wenn
die unzulänglichkeiten afghanischen
armee mussten über all die jahre durch
amerikanische truppen kompensiert werden
die ihren einsatz kosten jedoch bei über
einer million dollar pro einheit und
jahr liegen das schlimmste ist jedoch
dass die afghanische armee es deswegen
nie geschafft hat sich zu konsolidieren
eine moderne armee zu werden eine solche
besteht nun mal nicht nur aus soldaten
die eine waffe tragen und schießen
können nein der afghanischen armee fehlt
es zum beispiel an technikern und
mechanikern aller art an quartier
meistern und an medizinischen
fachkräften das alles gibt es in
afghanistan einfach nicht denn dazu
bräuchte es eine leistungsbereite
zivilgesellschaft mit einer breiten und
gebildeten mittelschicht
[Musik]
und so etwas kann nur über generationen
entstehen oder eben gar nicht in einem
land das von bildungs- und emanzipation
feindlichen traditionen dominiert wird
im grunde genommen verschwendeten bush
und rumsfeld mit ihren fatale
inkompetenten entscheidungen nicht nur
die chancenreichsten jahre afghanistans
sondern sie legten den grundstein für
jene grassierende korruption die haben
auswirkungen wir jetzt sehen können
wie ihr sehen könnt wurden die größten
fehler also schon ganz zu anfang gemacht
und mit der zeit potenzierten sie sich
ins unermessliche nicht zuletzt weil es
viele nicht auch ganz einfach wollten
dass die demokratie in afghanistan
scheitert so zum beispiel ist ein
direkter nachbar pakistan dieser ist ein
doppelt wenigkeit wohl kaum zu
überbieten denn eigentlich gibt sich das
land nach außen als verbündeter der usa
und hat von diesen in 16 jahren seit 33
milliarden dollar an militärhilfen
eingestrichen viele afghanen und
analysten sagen jedoch dass die
pakistanische armee während dieser
ganzen zeit alles getan hat um die
amerikanischen anstrengungen in
afghanistan zu sabotieren so gut essen
gehen heimlich wurden tausende von
taliban trainiert ausgerüstet logistisch
versorgt und sogar offiziere berater und
truppen an sie ausgeliehen mit anderen
worten die afghanische armee hat es die
ganze zeit tatsächlich nicht nur mit
einem haufen hindukusch nichts zu tun
gehabt sondern mit laptop die
größtenteils von einer viel größeren und
professionelleren armee ausgebildet
wurde aber warum sollte pakistan die
taliban unterstützen nun hauptsächlich
um afghanistan kontrollieren und den
einfluss indiens zurückzudrängen
außerdem geht es auf pakistan um die
pipeline die das land eines tages mit
gas versorgen könnte und warum sollte
man dabei nicht auch noch ein paar
milliarden von den dummen ungläubigen
einstreichen und diese schön an der nase
herumführen
dies sind also die vier
schlüsselfaktoren die wir in betracht
ziehen müssen um den schnellen fall
afghanistan zu verstehen alles in allem
sind die bilder die wir gesehen haben
ein großer schandfleck für das
krisenmanagement der regierung beiden
das chaos die anspannung der mangel an
koordination die gewalt und die toten
ein desaster epischen ausmaßes was ein
friedlicher rückzug werden sollte
entartete zum blutigen massaker das
erste mal seit anfang 2000 20 kam wie
der us soldaten in afghanistan ums leben
die taliban treiben die internationalen
truppen vor sich her und haben dabei
noch nicht einmal diesen abkommen von
doha versprochen haben die anderen
terrorgruppen im griff dies beweist der
jüngste bombenanschlag am flughafen in
kabul biden hatte ihr eine rasche und
energische antwort für den fall
angedroht dass amerikaner angegriffen
würden aber wen will commander-in-chief
beiden jetzt antworten die taliban
distanzierten sich von diesem angriff
und gegen das haben die usa und kaum
eine direkte handhabe mehr außer die
taliban erlauben es ihnen gnädigerweise
was also können wir jetzt von den
taliban erwarten werfen sie ihr
versprechen aus dora halten können oder
wird afghanistan die das wirkungsstätte
des global islamischen terrors die große
preisfrage lautet nämlich ob die taliban
entdeckte ich überhaupt etwas gegen den
nun beginnende dreher kriegt ausrichten
können zumal deren mitglieder zum großen
teil ehemalige taliban sind denen die es
einfach nicht radikal genug waren
sollten die taliban also zuseher mit den
usa kuscheln und die revitalisierung des
landes nicht schnell genug voran treiben
werden sicherlich weitere von ihnen zu
überlaufen die doha zugrundeliegende
rechnung der amerikaner würde dann ganz
und gar nicht auf den ist also die von
den amerikanern erhoffte stabilität am
hindukusch eine genauso große illusion
die ihre fatale fehleinschätzung die
taliban würden kabul erst ins müssen
dass anderthalb jahre nach absolut
truppen annehmen können wie sie noch vor
kurzem vorhergesagt haben welche zukunft
erwartet auch gar nicht an welche
perspektive haben die afghanischen
frauen hat der kümmerlichen widerstand
im lande eine chance diesen und anderen
wichtigen fragen werden denn in zwei
kommen videos afghanistan hier auf das
wort gründlich nachgehen also vergesst
nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren und
falls dieses video interessant fast dem
auch ein kleines land macht gut und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]